francia es el último país que sufre una
huelga aeroportuaria el viernes el mayor
aeropuerto del país el charles de gaulle
se llenó de pasajeros cuyo vuelo fueron
cancelados o retrasados después de que
el personal de tierra iniciara una
huelga por las condiciones salariales y
laborales
[Aplausos]
cuando llegamos a parís no hubo ningún
problema pero ahora mi mujer está en una
fila enorme para intentar facturar las
maletas pero está muy lleno
me preocupa tener que quedarme en parís
esta noche e intentar tomar otro vuelo
por la mañana
en total se cancelaron el 17% de los
vuelos con origen y destino a la capital
francesa los pasajeros tuvieron que
subir con sus maletas por la rampa de
acceso a la terminal ya que los
huelguistas cerraron las vías de acceso
reclaman un aumento salarial de 300
euros para combatir el alza de los
precios y la escasez de personal tras la
pandemia
los niveles de pasajeros han vuelto a
ser prácticamente los mismos que antes
del cob y sin embargo tenemos 20 mil
empleados menos y hemos perdido una
medida del 5 por ciento de nuestros
salarios así que no creemos que estas
condiciones de trabajo sean viables
[Música]
la interrupción en los aeropuertos
podría continuar durante todo el fin de
semana